vous allez devoir chanter façon opéra et
les se marre déjà échoué mardi
alors si tu te fous de ma gueule je me
marre avant petit exemple de ce que
pourrait faire un mauvais choix de
chanson je n'ai pas couru un peu plus
classique
ouais tu évolues avait alors vous sentez
alexandrie alexandra on m'a dit une
chanson récente
non on année on a mis une chanson non je
dirais c'est moche très moche je permets
pas de ce que les récents ou pas alors
la reprise au bond s'essayant façon
ténor quand même comme ma mauvaise et
dans le fond les investit alors gros
plans vous êtes gentil sur moi a réagi
non il a une tête alexandrie où l'amour
dans son fonds d'aidé qu'est ce que
c'est
il a essayé il a même pas essayé
franchement ici on dit la vérité
toujours oui bonsoir bernard sachiez
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
après et celle que nos mères après après
6 mai lire comment ça va d'abord j'ai
des gros poumons mais pas sans moyens
quand même tu as du coffre bon alors
c'est quand même d'accord et c'est quand
même moi je vous dis ce que j'ai choisi
on sent écouté
alors oui des fois qu'on reconnaisse pas
où c'est possible la plage est comme la
vie d'artiste
allez mes chansons je suis désolé pour
jenson chaud chaud chaud chocolat
[Musique]
je sais pas pourquoi je sais pas
pourquoi tous les vendredis au ont fait
cette séquence on voit que quand la
vidéo c'est un désert et la bonne
volonté sa volonté ça ne suffit pas à
mon petit maxime laetitia ce soit avec
vous
[Applaudissements]
ouvert à tous
et ici à 25 ans dépêché un handicap qui
ne se voit pas forcément vous avez une
maladie fait des globules rouges qui
sont et qui sont atteints c'est ça c'est
ça c'est la drépanocytose vers la
conséquence est parfois vous ça vaut
mais complètement à terre cao cao
invalides
bon avant de chanter faites moi plaisir
quel est votre animateur préféré c'est
nikos ah bon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis demandé si la production
pourrait mettre des gens qui m'aiment
bien au chaud ça me ferait ça voyait
nous nous a alors j'arrive à trouver le
par alors yéti bible on n'en trouve pas
ça pour me lancer infos-eau mais elle
est là mais bon bref alors laetitia et
votre animatrice le fait que c'est une
m'accorde il aa oui mais ça m'étonne pas
ça me donne pas à ce qu'elle ait voulu
ressembler un peu alors j'ai un truc
j'ai un secret vous vous confiez vous
êtes la cam de verdès dans mille oui à
mettre dans le mille et vous allez on
s'est croisé dans les loges et ça fait
comme dans le film à vous savez les 101
dalmatiens
les deux me permettre celui qui a
vraiment essayé c'est bernard montiel et
gentiment laetitia lui a expliqué
qu'elle était amoureuse de l'homme de sa
vie
mais bien sûr je vous taquine est ce que
vous sentez bien non bon c'est pas grave
ici personne ne semble pas sont donc
sera pas pire que les deux boîtes
moi je dis soir jeudi soir mais c'est de
fally ipupa nati c'est ça alors version
opéra attention et droit 4 jeudi soir à
22h faites moi une version de chansons
façon ténor j andaluz aller là attention
à toi toi ma belle andalouse quoi si
belle que jaloux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah c'est pas mal quand même c'est la
meilleure prestation depuis le début
alors c'est un truc
et voilà